hello i'm johnny knoxville and i'm going
undercover on the internet
this is actually me
[Music]
oh why you gotta bring this up quora
how how much damage did johnny knoxville
do to his body while performing stunts
on jackass
and did he age rapidly hello louise
i started jackass for a brunette now i
have silver hair
so i guess i age pretty rapidly and i
don't know if this is
how much damage i did to my body on
jackass 4
or on all the movies i'm just going to
answer on jackass 4
otherwise we'll be here all day so on
jackass 4
i broke my wrist broke my rib and got a
pretty gnarly concussion which i had to
stay in the hospital for the weekend
so yeah which jackass actor had the most
injuries from the movie
series everyone has
gotten lots of injuries on four stevo
busted his shoulder and but i think
my weekend in the hospital was probably
the most severe injury
but there's there's you know things
happen
twitter
seriously it's actually me ex-sad girl
sosa
i know you're probably too amped on
adrenaline in the moment but do you
remember being in pain after you shot
yourself with the vest on
that's referring to when i tested a
bulletproof vest while
shooting myself with the 38. no there
wasn't pain it was just
fear i was because i i didn't have
enough money to buy a good vest i had
i bought the cheapest vest they had the
vest actually dispersed the
impact quite nicely it felt like someone
hit you in the chest with a shovel
uh so but it did there was no pain
it was just just fear
do stuntmen respect johnny knoxville
just curious
the stuntmen on the set like when i
first started doing films and jack acid
came out
i remember on my first film the stuntman
hey
they said hey you want to sit with us
during lunch we usually don't let actors
sit with us but you can sit with us you
know that was a real
honor to be able to sit with the stunt
guys because
what they do is unbelievable so yes i i
have a great deal of respect for them
and i think
they're all right with what what we do
where and how did jeff tremaine and
johnny knoxville find the jackass crew
well most of us came out of big brother
magazine
where jeff was the editor and i
was one of the contributors and pontius
was a writer
and they covered we man they covered
stevo and then
we kind of joined forces with ryan dunn
and ben margera from
the cky videos and that's how we and
preston
actually he was he was a wild card he
was on my couch
at the time the show came about and uh
we got aaron through dave england he's
like hey can
we shooting the pilot here can i bring
my buddy to shoot yeah bring him
imdb was able to make friends with two
of his heroes johnny cash and hunter s
thompson before their respective deaths
even buying a cabin and other
possessions from cash
i did get to meet uh hunter s thompson
right before his passing i met him
before years earlier he was amazing uh
pure character carried a a doctor's bag
around and it was filled with everything
a doctor would
have in a bag he was very prepared
i never got to meet johnny at the wilson
man 11.
when are you going to find a new crew
for a new generation jackass well i'm
glad you asked because we have
a few new cast members in the new
jackass we
wanted to bring in some new blood some
fresh faces
and so we reached out to all our friends
and we got jasper dolphin
from the loiter squad and jasper and
errol's first time
his dad dark shark who is hilarious
um we have eric monaca who is an action
point with me
zach holmes who i was aware of from
just seeing crazy things on the internet
i mean he's a bigger fellow and just
goes for it he's
really athletic rachel wolfson the
stand-up comedian
uh she's fantastic and poopies
boy can't can't you wait to meet poopies
he's
a total spagholi surfer type and just
we'll go for it uh so so hard
him and zach really um you got to watch
it because
they'll do whatever you ask them so it's
like
it's a lot of power to have we have to
respect that
more quora what is johnny knoxville's
sperm count
my sperm count these days i think
is very healthy but i remember one time
in russia when we were partying really
hard in around 2004
2005 we were in some urology
clinic sex museum
and we took my sperm count then and
it was rather meager
they put it under a slide you know and
they showed
they showed a healthy sperm under the
slide which it looked like you know
just thousands of fish swimming through
the sea and
then they put mine up there all you saw
were like
four or five dead soldiers on a
battlefield
ex and for the longest time and then
finally two
you saw two soldiers were about to have
a heart attack and they crossed and
when they crossed paths everyone in the
room stood up and applauded that's how
low my sperm count was then
but i've had two children since then and
i think it's recovered
why did johnny knoxville leave the
jackass tv series
it was an election year and joseph
lieberman came down hard on our
show we were doing and unfortunately we
had a few copycat incidences
he was wanting to be tough on hollywood
and he was pointing us out directly
which the network kind of froze
and they had to really
come down on us for certain things
because they were getting calmed down on
and we couldn't do the show like we had
been doing it
it turned into something else and i love
the show too much to
to compromise it we had like osha people
assigned to the show
saying you can't jump off anything
higher than three feet
you know the constraints that we
couldn't do the show
so i quit but then out of all that we
decided to do
the first jackass film which opened us
back up again
how much of the budget for the jackass
movies is insurance
[Laughter]
guy on the first movie they didn't
insure the whole movie they
insured per bid one bit we wanted to do
they wanted five million dollars to
insure it we wanted pontius dressed up
like a
in a devil costume going to one of those
pentecostal churches where they handle
snakes
and to do that they wanted five million
dollars and we're like well can't do
that idea
because the whole movie first movie
called six million we can't double the
budget for one bit
posted imdb johnny knoxville's eyeball
popped out of its socket
twice after he was injured while
shooting the scene on the alpine slide
it did pop out of its socket twice
you know i had a terrible concussion and
i didn't
know it at the time but i also
powdered this bone in my face it just
it didn't break it just disappeared and
i remember getting back from the
hospital that night and i had a little
blood in my
nose and i just kind of took my fingers
in blue right
and then my eyeball went
and i called the producer i'm like
i got to go back to the hospital my eye
just popped out he's like ah
i'm like no my eye just popped out he's
like i'll be right there
and then about a week later i was out
with pontius
and he said something funny and for
whatever reason
like i wasn't supposed to sneeze for six
weeks right
i wasn't allowed to sneeze for six weeks
which isn't
like if you got to you got to that was
the information i had but pontiac said
something funny and i went
i held my nose and laughed and went
so i had double vision pushed it back in
good times prior to jackass airing on
mtv the crew was given an opportunity
from saturday night live to perform
their stunts on a weekly basis they
declined but knoxville would host the
show in 2005.
right as we were getting ready to do the
pilot
for jackass saturday night live
did offer me like three to five minutes
each week
to do something whether it's a prank or
a stunt
and i met with lauren michaels at the
beverly hills hotel
and i was extremely grateful for the
opportunity
to sit across from that man and you know
really consider the offer i was working
in a restaurant a year before
you know and now i'm staying across from
lauren michaels but in the end
i decided that god jackass was something
that
me and all my friends were doing and we
had control of and
i just thought maybe i'll just bet on us
and i was very grateful for the offer
but i
i just bet on us more twitter okay this
is has a picture
of where i ruptured my ring finger and
did you
regain all the movement in it and how
long did it take
okay this is this is the one that's not
injured and let's see
it goes like that this is the one that
was injured
it doesn't go as far but it's pretty
good uh
i was promoting bad grandparents
at a fraternity and
i jumped up on the basketball net right
i was trying to climb up the basketball
net and i
snapped my tendon so
i didn't know it until later because
you know lots of drinking at the
fraternity
next instagram
picture of me in my rice olds
jersey from 1985. wait does that mean
you're actually good at baseball i
thought your talent was having no talent
i loved baseball i played baseball until
i was
18 like up until the week i was moving
to los angeles i played in a
you know i had a summer league team that
i was playing on until i left
i was actually decent in baseball it's
the only thing that i could say that i
was
actually decent in i i love it i was a
pitcher in first base
you youtube
yo concussion how many johnny knoxvilles
have you had
i would say 15 or 16
now um
yeah i think i'm uh i think
i'm good on concussions
all right kids that's it i'm signing off
the internet
see you around